the place is shown to this day and held
in March veneration where Ostwald
being about to engage erected the sign
of the Holy Cross and on his knees pray
to God that he would assist his
worshipers in their great distress it is
further reported that the cross being
made in haste and the hole dug in which
it wants to be fixed the king himself
fall off faith laid hold of it and held
it with both his hands till it was set
fast by throwing in the earth and this
done raising his voice he cried to his
army let us all kneel and jointly
beseech the true and living God Almighty
in his mercy to defend us from the
haughty and fierce enemy for he knows
that we have undertaken a just war for
the safety of our nation all did as
commanded and accordingly advancing
towards the enemy with the first dawn of
day they obtained the victory as their
faith deserved
in that place of prayer very many
miraculous cures are known to have been
performed as a token and memorial of the
Kings faith for even to this day many ha
want to cut off small chips from the
ward of the Holy Cross which being put
into water men or cattle drinking
thereof or sprinkled with that water are
immediately restored to
the place in English tongue is called
heaven field or the heavenly field which
name it formally received as a procedure
of what was afterwards to happen
denoting that there the heavenly trophy
would be erected the heavenly victory
began and heavenly miracles be wrought
to this day the same place is near the
wall with which the Romans formally
enclosed the island from sea to sea to
restrain the fury of the barbarous
nations as has been said before hither
also the brothers of the Church of
haggle starred which is not far from
thence repair yearly on the day before
that on which King Oswald was afterwards
slain to watch therefore the health of
his soul and having sung many Psalms to
offer for him in the morning the
sacrifice of the holy oblation and since
that good customers spread they have
lately built and consecrated a church
there which has attached additional
sanctity and honor to that place and
this with odour Esau for it appears that
there was no sign of the Christian faith
no church no water erected throughout
all the nations of the burnished
Schumann's before that new commander of
the army prompted by the devotion of his
faith set up the cross as he was going
to give battle to his barbarous enemy
[Music]
nor is it foreign to our purpose to
relate one of the many miracles that
have been wrought at this cross one of
the brothers of the same church of
huggles start whose name is both elm and
who is still living a few years since
walking carelessly on the ice at night
suddenly fell and broke his arm
a most raging pain commenced in the
broken part so that he could not lift
his arm to his mouth for the violence of
the anguish hearing one morning that one
of the brothers designed to go to the
place of the holy cross he desired him
at his return to bring him a bit of that
venerable wood saying he believed that
with the help of God he might thereby be
healed the brother did as he was desired
and returning in the evening when the
brothers were sitting at table gave him
some of the old moss which grew on the
surface of the wound as he sat at table
having no place to lay up that which was
brought him he put the same into his
bosom and forgetting when he went to bed
to put it by left it in his bosom
awaking in the middle of the nights he
felt something cold lying by his side
and putting his hand to feel what it was
he found his arm and hand as sound as if
he had never felt any such pain
[Music]
you